I have both exciting and sad news and
it's the same news and it really depends
on your perspective
Sarah Huckabee Sanders Donald Trump's
latest press secretary is going to be
leaving the administration by the end of
the year not the most vile member as
I've said before just because she lies
constantly but because she seems to
truly relish her belligerent lying and
manipulation of the press corps and
she's one of the most visible members of
the Trump administration and she's going
to be quitting according to a CBS News
report that by the end of the year Sarah
Huckabee Sanders will be gone and this
is a major blow to Donald Trump first of
all it's a major blow because she's one
of the main liars in his administration
one of the most public facing distorter
x' for this administration is Sarah
Huckabee Sanders and she's there to try
to sort of soften Trump's public
missteps but this is also big news
because it's yet another major staffer
quitting and you might say well David
that's no big deal
Sarah Huckabee Sanders leaves they'll
just promote deputy press secretary Raj
Shah to the secretary position
unfortunately Raj Shah is also going to
be quitting according to that same CBS
News report he hasn't picked an exact
date but he will also be going bye-bye
this is the continued implosion of the
Trump administration and Sarah Huckabee
Sanders she actually didn't negate the
truth of the report she just said she
hasn't said anything like that she
tweeted yesterday after the CBS story
broke quote the CBS News know something
I don't about my plans in my future I
was at my daughter's year-end
kindergarten event and they ran a story
about my plans to leave the White House
without even talking to me I love my job
and am honored to work for the President
of the United States nothing in that is
a denial right she's not denying that
she's quitting she's simply saying she
hasn't been asked about it for the
report arguably they didn't need to
because she probably blabbed to so many
people at the White House that she's
leaving that it got leaked it to CBS and
then they're reporting on it it's
possible that she's quitting because she
realized that her non-stop public lying
is both immoral
not good for the country I don't think
it's particularly likely I think that
it's something she's just sick of the
schedule or it's time for her to move on
I know she has at least one young kid
maybe two I don't think it's any kind of
grand realization that she's been
participating in the takedown of
American ethics for months by her
participation here I think she's just
sick of it he just realizes it's time to
go but it would be surprised if she
decided to stick around for a January in
February of 2019 yeah just despite CVS
to call them fake news who will take the
job that's a question I have right
because this is really a position that
has not been great for the people that
have done it Sean Spicer his first day
on the job the day Donald Trump was
inaugurated Sean Spicer embarrassing
himself by going out there and lying
about it was the biggest inauguration
crowd ever and it was incredible he left
Sarah Huckabee Sanders came in she was
able to pick up smoothly when she took
over for Sean Spicer and I was thinking
that she lies so much we can't even
trust her to tell the truth about her
quitting right she could be walking
across the White House lawn carrying
boxes of her stuff and she might say
fake news is a real problem and reports
have been misleading like she we can't
actually trust her to tell us the truth
about whether she's going to be quitting
or not we're just gonna have to wait and
see
yeah I remember Sean Spicer strategy was
always apologetics and making the story
about him right messing up so badly at
the job that he took the focus off of
Trump for a second Sarah Huckabee
Sanders more obfuscation yeah not
answering questions so I don't know who
the new press secretary will be but I'm
sure we'll grow to love them too I would
love to actually see Sean Hannity become
the press secretary you're kinda so ins
or Candace Owens yes that would actually
be even more interesting and the most
interesting thing here is not about
another major staffer quitting that's to
be expected it's been an administration
that has a real problem with that for me
it's the role of the press secretary
right I understand that the job of press
secretary is you've got to put the best
possible spin on what the White House is
doing you make everything seem planned
and sober and well-thought-out if you're
defending an administration's agenda and
that's your job there will be some
distortion there will be some debunk
talking points but Sarah Huckabee
Sanders is sort of a special case for me
in that she
this ability to brazenly and proactively
cover up what Trump has done and said
through demonstrable lies and deception
she should be ashamed of herself
based on her participation in this the
way I hope Sean Spicer is neither of
them realistically is actually
embarrassed by their behavior but this
is an administration that has set such a
low bar for press secretaries that I
hope that the I was just following
orders I was just doing my job excuse
will not be allowed to excuse their
behavior in the future because it has
set a truly new low standard it's a
pond-scum standard for what has been a a
position that yes they do get involved
in the talking points and the repetition
but not in this brazen and proactive way
send me your thoughts david pakman.com
slash re d di t quick break back after
this